Je me suis concentrée sur les violences
faites aux femmes
dans le monde du travail
De façon historique,
les femmes, aujourd'hui,
vont avoir des textes qui s'appliquent.
La lutte contre les écarts de salaires
entre les femmes et les hommes,
ça s'appelle la directive
transparence des salaires.
Il faut savoir quand même
qu'encore en moyenne,
on a 13% d’écart de salaire à travail
égal entre les femmes et les hommes
dans toute l'Union européenne.
C'est évidemment différent d'un pays à l'autre.
Ce texte, il a été adopté.
Jusqu'au bout, il va être transposé
et il va obliger les entreprises
à avoir plus de transparence.
Quand il y a des écarts de salaires, plus de 5%,
elles vont devoir mettre en place
un plan d'action correctif
et en tout cas publier tous les ans
ou tous les trois ans selon leur effectif,
des informations sur les écarts de salaires.
Et s'il y en a, il y aura même un risque de sanction.
Donc c'est quand même
un texte majeur
qui va aussi obliger
à informer tout candidat, toute candidate
ou tout salarié sur les salaires.
Comment on a établi
mon salaire à l'embauche ?
Comment il se positionne
par rapport au salaire des hommes
pour le même travail ?
Un second texte
est majeur pour les droits des femmes en Europe :
c'est une directive pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes.
Une femme sur sept fait l'objet
de violences conjugales de son conjoint
ou ex-conjoint avec des féminicides
malheureusement nombreux.
Et donc l'idée de ce texte,
c'est vraiment de trouver
des mesures adaptées de prévention
ou aussi de lutter contre la cybercriminalité
qui est un fléau
qui est en pleine croissance
et qui touche particulièrement les femmes.
Et moi, je me suis concentrée sur les violences
faites aux femmes
dans le monde du travail
et je défends l'idée d'un aménagement
du temps de travail pour ces victimes.
Et aussi un second point important
une formation pour les employeurs.